>>> I'VE JUST BEEN DOING A LOT
OF PRESS AND THESE DIFFERENT
JOBS, AND DON'T GET ME WRONG.
I'M REALLY, REALLY GRATEFUL.
I'M STARTING TO FEEL A LITTLE
BURNT OUT.
>> THAT SUCKS.
MARK, ARE YOU READY WITH THE
PLAY LIST?
>> AND I GOT THE SLURPIES!
>> DUDE, NICE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
>> WE'RE GOING ON A BEAUTIFUL
CROSS-COUNTRY AMERICAN ROAD
TRIP.
>> JUST US AND THE OPEN ROAD.
GOING TO BE AWESOME.
>> WAIT, CAN I COME?
♪♪
♪ HIT THE OPEN ROAD AND CATCH A
RIDE, ARMS GETTING TAN ON THE
SUNNY SIDE ♪
♪ I'M ON THE WHEEL, I'M ON NAV,
I'M ON SNACKS ♪
♪ AND JENNA'S JOB IS TO JUST
RELAX ON A ROAD TRIP, A GREAT
AMERICAN ROAD TRIP ♪
♪ WE'RE GOING ON A ROAD TRIP,
GOING ON A ROAD TRIP, HEY, OH ♪
♪ ROLL DOWN THE WINDOWS TO CLEAR
YOUR --
>> WE MISSED THE EXIT.
>> RECALCULATE YOUR ROUTE.
>> JUST LOOK OUT FOR THE NEXT
ONE.
NEED A LITTLE HEADS UP.
>> OKAY.
IT'S JUST A LITTLE HARD DOING
MUSIC AND NAV.
>> PRICE OF BEING SHOTGUN.
>> YEAH.
NO, IT'S FINE.
LET'S TRY TO FOCUS ON NAV, ALL
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I'LL FOCUS ON THE NAV.
>> YEAH, THANKS.
YOU'RE NOT IN CHARGE OF ME
♪ NOD TO CONVERTIBLES WHEN THEY
PASS, MOON A TRUCK OR PUT YOUR
CHEEKS ON THE GLASS ♪
♪ SEE A SIGN THAT SAYS WE'RE
GOING TO HELL ON THE ROAD TRIP,
A GREAT AMERICAN ROAD TRIP ♪
>> I'M SORRY.
CAN WE COOL IT WITH THE SLURPY
FOR A SECOND?
IT'S JUST RIGHT IN MY EAR.
>> SORRY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
I'M HAPPY TO BUY EVERYONE A
SLURPY, BUT YOU'RE SUCKING ON
THE -- THERE'S NONE LEFT.
>> CAN YOU SCOOT OVER, YOUR LEG
HAIRS ARE SCRATCHING ME.
>> FINE, I'LL MOVE MY LEG.
>> DID YOU JUST VENMO REQUEST ME
FOR THE SLURPY?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY, SO.
♪ WE'RE GOING ON A ROAD TRIP --
>> RECALCULATING ROUTE.
>> DID WE MISS THE GOD DAMN
COMMIT AGAIN?
>> WHO COULD YOU POSSIBLY BE
TEXTING THAT'S NOT IN THIS CAR.
>> IT WAS MY MOM, MAN.
MY DAD HAD A STROKE.
SORRY I'M NOT FOCUSSING ON THE
NAV!
I DON'T KNOW WHY I SAID THAT.
HE DID NOT HAVE A STROKE.
>> LIAR!
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> EVERYBODY, WE'RE HAVING QUIET
TIME.
READ A BOOK OR SOMETHING.
♪ FINALLY TIME TO CHILL, I CAN
DO WHAT I WANNA, DIVE INTO THE
THE NEW MICHELLE OBAMA.
>> I'M GOING TO PUKE!
PULL OVER RIGHT NOW!
>> 0.3 MILES!
>> MARK, THAT MEANS NOTHING TO
ME.
>> YOU TOLD ME TO FOCUS ON THE
NAV.
>> WE'RE GOING HOME!
>>.
♪ LATE AT NIGHT AND I FEEL SO
FREE, EVERYONE ASLEEP EXCEPT FOR
ME, ♪
♪ BIG BRIGHT MOON HANGING IN THE
SKY, NAV IN MY LAP --
>> WHAT JUST HAPPENED?
>> NOTHING.
GO BACK TO SLEEP EVERYONE.
THANKS.
WILL YOU TURN THE AC ON?
>> YEAH.
YOU HOT OR COLD?
>> BOTH.
>> I SAW WHAT YOU DID.
♪ ON A ROAD TRIP ♪